on va faire un point peut-être à présent
de l'autre côté de la place de la
république
on l'a vu dans notre édition spéciale
quelques heurts entre manifestants et
policiers quelques tirs de gaz
lacrymogène thomas gonnet bonjour
qu'en est il de ces tensions qu'elle
qu'est ce qui s'est passé exactement
qu'avez vous constaté sur place
en fait il ya eu des tensions après
plusieurs heures de manifestations
d'abord il ya eu ce rassemblement assez
massif avec plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes rassemblées sur
cette place de la république
rassemblement dans le calme est
effectivement lorsque la préfecture de
police a annoncé que le rassemblement
serait finalement statique et bien à ce
moment là les esprits sont un peu
échauffés en tout cas un petit groupe
d'individus sont nés pris un petit peu
avec eux c'est un peu échauffés avec les
forces de l'ordre des jets de
projectiles d'un côté gaz lacrymogènes
de l'autre j'ai eu plusieurs fois des va
et vient comme ça ça a duré un moment et
puis les choses sont redescendus grâce
notamment à l'intervention des
organisateurs qui ont appelé au calme
qui ont demandé aux personnes de ne plus
jeter des projectiles et ça a fonctionné
puisque la tension est redescendue assez
rapidement alors il ya eu encore
quelques petits soucis au moment de la
dispersion puisqu'en fait certaines
personnes ne savaient pas vraiment pas
où il fallait sortir les forces de
l'ordre leur indiquer une sortie puis
finalement lorsqu'il se présentait on
leur disait que c'était une autre sortie
c'est assez courant dans les fin de
manifestation les choses sont désormais
revenus à la normale puisque vous le
voyez les personnes présentes à ce
rassemblement sont en train de quitter
cette place de la république
beaucoup de personnes qui étaient
présentes ici sur cette place pour faire
porte faire entendre leurs
revendications
une convergence des luttes notamment
avec des gilets jaunes qui étaient
également présents je propose d'écouter
jérôme rodriguez sur la question des
violences policières
aujourd'hui on nous est allé manifester
la policière s'est pris la liberté qui
est la sienne aujourd'hui en tant que
citoyen français de pouvoir manifester
sur les champs-elysées et nous on nous
empêche de prendre le chemin de la
manifestation
mais ça va paraître fou mais ils ont
droit
la france est un pays libre et
démocratique je cautionne pas le message
leur message c'est de la merde de
pouvoir manifester pour avoir le droit
d'être anglais pour avoir le droit de
mutilés y a pas pire message mais on vit
dans un pays qu'est la démocratie
à eux de parler à eux de s'expliquer à
nous de les contredire
mais pourquoi nous aujourd'hui on n'a
pas le droit de manifester pourquoi moi
aujourd'hui j'ai perdu année parce que
j'ai pris ce droit de manifester la
justice ne donnera pas raison il n'y
aura pas de justice
comme pour tous les gilet jaune mutilés
voilà donc pour les revendications
portées lors de cette manifestation qui
est donc en train de s'achever les
forces de l'ordre dont les voix sont en
train de pousser les manifestants vers
la sortie même si apparemment ça bloque
un peu évidemment ya beaucoup de monde
qui souhaitent quitter la place de la
république en même temps d'autres
actions sont d'ores et déjà prévues pour
les prochaines semaines merci thomas
pour toutes ces précisions